>> Greg: PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
BE TAKING THE PODIUM ANY MINUTE.
WONDER WHERE HE’S GOING TO TAKE
IT?
PEOPLE WHO USE SOCIAL MEDIA THE
MOST ARE THE WORST PEOPLE IN THE
UNIVERSE.
A NEW STUDY TRACKING SNAPCHAT
AND FACEBOOK USE FOUND THAT THE
HEAVIEST USERS TEND TO ENJOY
UPSETTING AND EMBARRASSING OTHER
PEOPLE AND ARE MOTIVATED BY
CRUELTY AND PERSONAL GAIN.
SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT.
WHEN I GET OFF SOCIAL MEDIA, I
RARELY FEEL BETTER THAN I DID
WHEN I GOT ON PERHAPS BECAUSE WE
NOT ONLY RUN INTO CREEPS MORE
FREQUENTLY, WE ALSO CAN CONTROL
THE ENCOUNTERS.
MAYBE I AM THE CREEP.
I BELIEVE I’M A BETTER PERSON
HERE THAN THERE WHICH IS HARD TO
BELIEVE WHICH LEADS THE GOOD
NEWS.
THE OUTSIDE WORLD IS INDEED A
BETTER PLACE THAN THE NET.
EXCEPT PORTLAND.
IN GENERAL ALL PEOPLE ARE BETTER
HERE THAN ONLINE.
FAR MORE OF THEM ARE WEARING
CLOTHES.
WE DO OURSELVES NO GOOD TO THINK
TWITTER REFLECTS PLANET EARTH.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
IDIOTS WHO DO.
POLITICIANS VIEW TWITTER AS AN
INSTANT POLL.
IF THEY SEE EXTREMISM ONLINE,
THEY MOVED THERE.
TWITTER BECOMES THEIR GPS.
THE MEDIA DOES THE SAME THING.
IT’S "THE NEW YORK TIMES" ENTIRE
PROFIT MODEL.
YOUNG MINDS FIND THEMSELVES MORE
AFFECTED BY OPINIONS OF ONLINE
STRANGERS THAN THEIR LOVING
PARENTS.
MAYBE THAT’S WHY SO MANY YOUNG
UNSTABLE UNEMPLOYED ADULTS FIND
JOY IN DESTROYING PROPERTY,
COMMUNITIES, CAREERS, LIVES IN
ALTERNATELY THEMSELVES.
THEY GET A HEAD START ONLINE AN
END THEN ON THE STREET THEY LET
HER IN VANDALISM AND ARSON.
SUGGESTING YOU SHOULD AVOID
SOCIAL MEDIA DOESN’T MEAN IT
WILL AVOID YOU.
TURNING IT OFF DOESN’T MAKE THE
MOB DISAPPEARED.
IF EVERYONE ELSE INCLUDING YOUR
EMPLOYER TAKES THEM SERIOUSLY.
UNTIL THAT STOPS, WE ARE TOTALLY
SCREWED.
WE’VE GOT TO BE SUPER BRIEF.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS STUDY,
JESSE?
>> Jesse: I DO AND I CAN TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW THAT EVERY TIME I
GO ON TWITTER I ONLY FIND OUT
TRUMP IS EITHER SENILE, RACIST,
EVIL, DOESN’T BELIEVE IN SCIENCE
AND WANTS TO YOUR CHILDREN OR --
OR KANYE MIGHT HAVE SAID
SOMETHING BANANAS.
I CHECK IT ONCE IN THE MORNING
AND I CHECK IT RIGHT AT 6:00 TO
SEE IF I HAVE SAID ANYTHING
CONTROVERSIAL I NEED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR.
>> Greg: THAT’S ALL IT IS.